Baychester Middle School is located in the
Edenwald section of the Bronx.
Most of our students are qualified for Title
One, which means that the majority of our
students are low-income students.
My goal with teaching sixth-grade science
is primarily focused on engagement because
I feel if students are engaged, and interested,
they will then want to continue to study.
So without that initial engagement, or really
enjoyment of learning, they’re not going
to want to pursue science at later ages.
So I do a lot of hands-on activities.
I try to mix things a lot with visuals, kinesthetic
examples, songs, movement — body movements
— in different ways so that students remember
the content and also are engaged and are enjoying
being in class.